yeah he's a little bit loud but uh all
right guys
surprise drop from blizzard you know
that if me and Joey I'm Eric that's Joey
if you know we're in here and there's
kind of purple lights on can only mean
one thing
maura the newest character in overwatch
is available in PTR here she is that
means she is available on PC on the
public test realm sorry to the people on
console you won't be able to play her
obviously but dude oh that person has a
skin or some David Bowie's skin oh [ __ ]
we gotta go check out the skins too so
let's go do that in a second
yeah but if you have PC you can go out
and download it now she's available for
free on PTR assuming you own the game
we're gonna check out her skin they
didn't show her skins already I think
during the Blizzcon which just wrapped
up recently
you got ornate cool you got pale it's
just white that's nice clean Minister
which I guess she will Wed you to death
do you part
Oasis which is kind of the same thing
just gold and then you got glam David
Bowie and moon which is also did that
one's probably use my PTR PTR money oh
wow it's only a thousand yeah well it's
nice so we're gonna go in as David Bowie
essentially or a little shout-out to
David Bowie but thank you guys all for
tuning in this is a last minute stream
obviously we did not know him we're was
gonna come out today Joey literally
tweeted into our breaking chat that oh
by the way Blizzard tweeted out that
she's available on PTR I was kind of
curious myself because I saw my PTR
update and I was like that can only
really mean one thing yeah and here she
is she's available for all those that
weren't able to go to Blizzcon to play
her and now you can play her on PC
that's pretty good and so yeah we're
live on YouTube twitch gamespot twitter
and facebook if you guys have questions
throw them on over to me and Joey I
actually got to play her at Blizzcon as
well as check I got to check out the
Blizzard world map which I don't know if
it's in is in this we'll have to see
don't move Blizzard world map was sick
yeah it was awesome it's like if you
mean me and Justin did impressions on
multiple things at Blizzcon overwatch
being one of them but if you didn't see
that video one check it out and two if
not it's very Disneyland ask it was
pretty appropriate when Jeff Kaplan was
like ah how many people here are going
to the theme park yeah well guess what
we have a theme park and the thing that
was really cool about it is there's just
a lot of subtle touches like even the
posters look really like theme park ask
and very like overwatch ask there's like
you know your directory map of like
here's this land here's that land here's
this look like different sections yeah
yeah so like if you look down at it and
the funny thing is I was at Disneyland
yesterday I was looking at one of those
kind of like directory maps of like
here's like you know Fantasyland here's
tomorrow in Tomorrowland and all those
places the Blizzard world one has one
too and if they if it's in here will
show you if not all good
oh you know what I screwed up on the
twitch title I that twitch probably
still says horizon zero dawn I'll fix
that right now I apologize for that it's
not horizon zero dawn we didn't horizon
zero dawn earlier today I will fix that
right now that is my bad I literally
came into this room and started making
all of our stream things and that was
the one thing I forgot so I apologize to
all the people who got the notification
for that I'm sorry I'm typing and I
can't think and talk at the same time
but yeah she's the new support hero
you've only just got to see you played
one game so yeah you don't really have a
feel for her obviously yet but cool to
see you guys support hero and to me she
has like a kind of Zenyatta Symetra high
braid a little bit she has to do damage
and she gets to heal her teammates did
you see the the the emotes yeah let's
take a look I think I skimmed through
him okay at your surface okay
uh yeah a little beckoned yeah yeah yeah
give and take and take it away laughs
that's good okay and then waiting OS or
sit cool so there's the emotes Angelo
loco there you go
hi Stefan thank you guys all for tuning
in what's up blue dad how you doing the
game browsers sometimes people just like
make them
No Limits vs. AI you're gonna play the
hey hi well I mean just a show do it
that's fair that's fair
why haven't we gotten a new defense here
oh yeah that's a good question useful
Julian I do not know I wouldn't be
shocked if that happens eventually but
or is this this is the new spectator cam
right yes get the play or what see
where's everyone
how come you don't get to play we were
trying to get into the game with stuff I
wasn't that we weren't trying to get
into a game it's just my my guess is a
lot of people don't know that this is
out the tweet was not very revealing it
has like basically a Torbjorn turret
which doesn't scream out to me that says
more hey Moyes available yeah it's like
it's weird they actually reference her
like her name at all in the in the tweet
except for in the in the link I think
yeah so we're currently spectating
because we can't get into a game which
is kind of unfortunate a bunch of people
are spectating there's basically trying
to find a game I know with all the
people in this game you would think that
they were finding a normal game but
there yeah
actually let me do this instead one just
fine with like Laura you know twelve
quick yeah when is we're out there's not
a hard confirmed to date in terms of
where and she'll be out it kinda I think
Jeff said something like early next year
but I don't know if that was the
character or leanings here maybe no
sorry I have too many Blizzcon dates in
my head
well they said PG are very soon
obviously this is me soon this is like a
day week or two days out of this con I
can't remember
I could be miss speaking so next year
stuff on early 2018 is what Sadler said
so yeah so I was I think that's what he
they said PTR soon and then like next
early next year for the actual release
alright so here we're waiting but we can
actually or no we're good thanks we
stopping for the suggestion I'm fighting
AI this is this is fine if this doesn't
work out we could always fight the AI
just to show you guys alright I should
write teams yeah she's pretty cool again
as mentioned you can heal or DPS with
her it's part gonna be a lot of madness
it's probably gonna be a lot of 6p6
Moroz so just expect that yeah that's
how it always is whenever a new
character comes and the thing that
always happens is we decide hey we're
gonna try to counter her and then
everyone's like we're here for more oh
aren't you playing war uh there's a guy
playing tour right here alright there
you go he's on our team Ellie's he's
like I I know the answer to more we're
good there we go
but yeah cool yeah if you guys have
questions or anything like that shoot
him on over I had some hands-on time
with her at Blizzcon was fortunate
enough to be there as a pretty exciting
one I actually thought it was gonna be
pretty light yeah I didn't think that
they would have as much to show now
technically most of the stuff they
showed isn't necessarily like
extraordinary I guess like you're used
to probably seeing a cinematic you're
used to the potential like like there
was a potential for yeah there's a
potential for a new hero I thought that
was a little bit unlikely but you know
obviously that ended up happening the
cinematic was awesome the Reinhardt's of
divinity I wish we could dual wield
hammers that would be like the sickest
we'll check out her gold weapon in a bit
raw sage that's a good call and so yeah
like I think Wow classic was probably
one of the bigger
I think which makes sense it's
interesting because Justin got to talk
to the devs about you know Wow classic
you know when wins the hope for it to
come out in all those things and they
were pretty open in regards to talking
about it but they themselves don't even
have a date for it yet they like aren't
sure how exactly it's gonna work yet you
know like are they gonna keep it truly
vanilla are they gonna add some of the
like bring some of the quality of life
stuff
there's orbs in our base yeah that tends
to happen so yeah that's one of our
abilities one of uh you can either use
that to heal or to do damage it bounces
around and does quite a bit of damage
and it's probably really bad in these
close quarters because it basically
keeps bouncing I want to say it seemed
like the duration of the cooldown but I
didn't actually try to time as close and
then here you go he's using his/her
right-click ability which is her
damaging ability which is kind of
reminiscent of symmetric turret hears
left click healing you see there's a
gauge on it so you can do you guys
really spam it and also it's not that
fast to come back like if you see it
there like if joy stops look at it
doesn't come back that so that's my
understandings that you need to use the
the drain ability to recharge it plug it
you're pretty much like it balances like
the attack and healing pretty well yeah
yeah churches up pretty well so there
you go there's the bouncy ball her other
ability which I think Joey is done oh
there's a there's the alt in heels and
damages so you it doesn't do that much
damage so it like it's yeah because it
can't do too much damage because
obviously it's dual purpose feeling and
damaging so imagines and Yaga's also
dick damage we yeah that would be crazy
actually I would take that I think he
just used his fate abilities which is
her movement mechanic it is it makes you
invulnerable to damage but you can't do
damage at the same time it can go left
right forward or backwards and you can
kind of control that mid teleport or
fade yeah the thing is you can't
vertically do it so it's not like
we can teleport to a platform yeah it's
more like coming Tracy I guess yeah her
walk speeds okay so like if you don't
like if you're trying to get back into
the fray you're gonna need to spam the
fatal yeah yeah it does cover some
pretty decent distance though this is
good there enough there in like a
hallway Oh where'd he go oh he's
probably right back - the way
oh it's speeds are up a little bit yeah
the whole sorry unfortunately for those
asking about console uh when when
characters are on PTR there's sadly only
on PC this is where the public test
realm servers are so unfortunately you
guys will have to wait so she's out
proper in the wild which I think we're
saying is roughly early next year so but
for all the people that have PC you can
go out and download and try her now
she is out in the wild oh you are right
got to get in there yeah but the faith
the feed is pretty disorienting to when
you're fighting someone because you
don't exactly know where they go they
can go in yeah they don't like tracer
where you have to go either what's a
ball bouncy ball
Mostafa a super I saying she has decent
health for support yeah she just 200
which is pretty like pretty like
standards and Jana is 150 right his is
200 bubble shield yeah look like 150
shields yeah uh
Gabe Newell Wow being blessed by Gabe
Newell again this is crazy
saying doofus took about two weeks for -
you know it's a release after a PTR
we'll see
not sure when we'll get her but here's a
hoping sooner than late
yes stay on the line stay on the line so
she can't use any of her other abilities
like what people were doing when I was
when we were fighting each other like
that whenever they got like a low or 50%
they were just like fade and then I
totally lose them because of you know
just the nature of how that works but
yeah I would say if you're gonna play
her it's like you want to try to fade
not like as a last resort but as a good
like kind of way to disorient the
opponent while you guys are fighting
they think of it kind of like sombras
where she just like gets in there but
still packs and then like jumps out I
mean yeah I'm not sure a team if it's
early next day sorry
also like I'm not 100% sure on the next
year thing so everyone needs to relax
about that that's just what I thought I
heard for the UH that the map then the
map and then maybe the skins that they
they announced oh yeah okay yeah yeah
you're right the the blizzard skins yeah
yes so she might be sooner sorry about
that
like I said I just got back from
Blizzcon my brain is mush there's been
so many announcements all this is Orion
yeah someone's trying to play this legit
huge egos
see like I ran out of hewing charge now
I have to go I have to go on the
offensive
charge it into the yes in the spawn
point they won't want to come out
through that oh they're getting serious
she's dead
the and the the beam is pretty decent
range yeah I was surprised by it so yeah
her gold gun is on palm of hands and
wrists yeah we'll check that out in a
bit it's just that ooh yeah that's nice
that was a nice lip that's the that's
the marriage one the marriage okay got
the heels got some heels probably kills
this person right yeah okay this is a
long play of the game how the hell'd TF
was that play of the game that's good
question yeah I don't know because like
she don't she doesn't have any like
explosions or like things that will like
Ottoman or things that would take off
like huge chunks oh yeah it always had
to be like a bunch of people are damaged
and you're finishing them off the
mattress like what using her gun it just
like tracks them and then like kills
them and moves on to the next one yeah
we are using the one of the four
legendary skins for Moira it's kind of
like a David Bowie yeah so we'll check
out our gold weapon in a bit I know you
guys are asking but let us finish a
match because what's gonna happen right
away for us is the moment we get out of
the game everyone's gonna be like why
are you not playing the game and that's
gonna be that so yeah cool but yeah
pretty cool stuff that she's out and
available on PTR that was very fast they
says shortly I was gonna like a couple
like Tuesday oh I've been one day
because like Tuesday's usually they're
maintenance when will this character be
available for available for console
asking the amazing otaku reaiiy it's
hard to say a lot of people are doing
their speculations of one to two weeks
after PTR which has kind of been their
calling card you know with doing this
bra but we'll have to see I'm sure
they're putting in a PT yard
you get some better testing honor
obviously it's gonna be hard when people
are just playing six or five mortars
here we got one deal diva so yeah if you
try to to fade up there it won't work
yeah that's the best you can do you can
jump and do it but like most high places
you're not going to be able to get to
which is fair because I think I'd be too
good
you could go vertical vertically as well
well Barry let's sit there yeah
all right so everybody would get out you
guys not getting in there
he has six potential healers Hugh do
some geometry yeah yeah look at that
whole geometric look at Joey doing the
math on the stream here she'll probably
do more geometry than then I'll do those
because the console just inspires one
shine and it just sprays wherever we're
actually not think about it long enough
I'll go I'll go for it and then it's
gonna come back fun putting the Hanzo
means on blast your geometry was poor
you're home and walking so I'm gonna go
through Oh melter there's too many she's
just you know there's so much stuff
going on oh that person's on the case no
you don't
where'd you go yeah he Oh your team
there's other one with the beam look at
that doing like paltry damage oh these
are all ya got fisherman
I just feel as I don't reload at all we
stopped a soup a saying it makes no
sense why she can't use both hands
together I think it takes so much
concentration and power
yeah you can only oh my god those are
bad geometry on those healing balls see
like that guy should have backed off
what's he used what do you think you're
doing she also has a beam
oh yeah fishing man down okay so I have
to use yeah you want fire nice
show them that geometry get math ok need
LS okay people are getting serious now
they're getting tired of being bullied
it took like four shots at me
you're definitely not buying it on Steam
but good joke captain buzz thanks for
tuning in I appreciate your tongue no
that way not that way
really that's not his full health
unfortunate
I would die yeah you might have been the
fara have a junk rat too great
they're playing serious business here
where as you got for my res though it's
McCree though seems about right still
have the diva she's gonna take some time
big yeah it was actually like reverse
psychology captain bud it was my way of
trolling you but I guess that went over
your head that take some time get used
to the the trajectory on the yield thing
this is like the thing is uh you know
that the healing or have also heals you
right yeah
[Music]
there was gold do it Stefan get on and
play some play you somewhere oh my god
dance to rocket ah huh I'm surprised he
didn't chase you I would have Oh even
better
well played the same guy though I wasn't
okay say that was an outplay when he saw
me come on he's playing a long time he's
playing a long time really
Wow Farah Blackpool EDG thinks words
gonna get nerfed and no one's gonna play
her anymore the best line was from Jeff
when he said Jeff - stuff like the way
you spell her name is opa f he's for the
first week yeah
everyone thought that about sambar - and
then she turned out to be just be like
pretty happy Saul yeah not like
overpowered really oh my what's up afro
legacy how are you doing today good
afternoon
maybe night for you depending on where
you're at is the range on those words
yes there's balls everywhere
Oh God
well you win no no symmetric turrets
still feel better what was your favorite
Blizzard overwatch skin just ever know
from the one so you know how like they
just let me think
I'll go first I think butcher road hog I
will definitely get cuz I I love Diablo
yeah and it just makes perfect sense and
then Widowmaker Nova is pretty cool too
yeah so you would have just got sniped
by Nova I really like the other yeah
black card I think what's up wko 511
cross gaming unfortunately we don't sell
games weird game spots but it's bad idea
thank you for tuning in I think you guys
are done mainly because they went like
three serious characters to you're like
one or two there they're also down one
it doesn't matter they pushed you try
harder on test server so good some
person is not happy hate project oh is
this
oh yeah
sounds alright what did you get quad the
cheap quad weight was symmetric beam
range long longer than Juarez looks like
it's been closed look like it there cuz
like you were channeling huge channeling
and your stop doing damage I wonder if
it's like you need to be more accurate
with moyers maybe mmm that might be it
because I feel like I lost it doesn't
track it nearly as well as
symmetrization now please okay sure
take a look we can jump back into it
yeah pretty easy to get back in so we
got yeah I guess her rings - but it's
not like super obvious like upgrading
her jewelry kid Indian saying where is
this longer by far as noticeable but I
think it could be um like you said it
could be dependent on if you're actually
aiming it yeah properly versus just kind
of like willy-nilly holding it someone
said just check it out and maybe like
training practice range what check what
I like her uh the range of her oh versus
symmetric yeah sure wonder let's do some
Theory crafting here day one in PTR
theorycrafting not even final version
zero meters
or 10 meters yes 10 meters up I think is
like the one thing I was wondering is
how will it track
so if I were to go like over here you
just lose them okay where's the metros
you just hold it and it would stay yeah
so if you're if you're Symetra like in
this saber one-77 we showed the
animations already so if you actually
scrub back DVR style to the beginning of
the stream you'll see some of those
animations wow it is seven meters away
how is the tracking okay yeah that's
pretty forgiving whereas you can't even
go like yeah damn look at this
myth-busting right here is like catching
people when they're running around or
you're jumping around them mm-hmm
like you see some it was always going
like this or whatever just it'll stay
track whereas more probably won't be
able to do that as much I have to be a
little more accurate
so it wasn't twice as long kind of kid
Indiana has about three meters J fantasy
she is out on PTR right now
so you can check it out if you have PC
victory cutscenes are also there they
were all of that stuff we we showed so
he said go to the farther ones are there
further targets I mean like we pretty
much just showed the difference right
yeah we could see there's like some
distance right here so this is 0 to 10
meters so like she can get it or that's
roughly about the range on let's see oh
no wow it is almost double that wait you
know maybe let's go to the the further
ones here the ones we were just at okay
I got it yeah yeah we're on it
sorry there stream delay killed it so
that's what 20 meters away I think
yeah 20 meters so here at 10:15 Wow okay
so it is done go even 20 Wow I told you
she had rain that's pretty yeah okay
that makes that makes up for it so it's
like you get the
since but it's less forgiving because
like if you pulled it even like a little
bit ah like no maybe not a little bit
but like enough off yeah so if you're a
pretty accurate with this you can who is
this thirty meters no no that's too far
no yeah okay like 21
so yeah it's almost tripled I mean
that's pretty that's almost triple I I
wouldn't have guessed if you were this
far away from them you'd be able to to
drain it like that way you don't get to
jump around so if you're like following
someone like right here yeah be harder
right yeah you can like you can almost
like sneak up on they won't really know
yeah that's why I said like doing the
fader earlier yeah it's almost better
because I like feedback and then you go
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so if like they
search if they start chasing you or
someone who can be like that's pretty
good
we do not know when she's actually gonna
be available she just got put on the PTR
today which is a lot sooner than we
thought
cool if there's anything else he wants
to test tell us but uh that is pretty
crazy 20 20 plus meters or 20 20 21
meters or the last one let me check the
range on the the old so let's see this
will be 40 meters
so 30 meters arrange for the that's Perl
that's pretty far yeah but it doesn't do
that much damage doesn't do that much
but yeah but you could you could you
could obsessively heal and damage from
really one place pretty safe yeah a lot
of people erroneous botch says they're
gonna nerf the [ __ ] out of her
I don't know until you see her see
here's the thing we always tried these
out in like the not a real life
situations yeah so it's like how good is
she really in like a real game yeah I
was like I felt more overpowered with
like doofus and and they nerfed him
yeah they nerfed him yeah but you've
only played like two games yeah but
still it's like her her powers don't
seem immediately like that strong
compared to some of the other characters
that we've seen like yeah she has like a
teleport and she can do damage and heal
but either like both are damaged and her
healing is neither way like that
powerful mm-hmm like her life strain is
like this pretty good but it's not good
you have to stay yeah for like five
seconds like non-stop in order to to
kill them I think it'll be about like
how accurate are you with the balls
that's the question
yeah he's gonna be a ball man yeah or a
master of geometry all right cool why
don't you hop back in a match if you
guys have other stuff we need to test we
can always get back into the training
range but good shout there from you guys
to kind of see what her range would be
like and it turns out it's three times a
Symetra so it requires a little bit more
aim though back to 66 limits Moira
so I got 10 second cooldown on her orbs
select your hero uh Haroon rahim how I
just bought overwatch how hard is it to
learn um it depends I think there's a
lot there's a good variation of skill in
terms of the game in terms of the
different heroes I think that you should
try some of the easier ones to start and
then kind of try other ones or if you
like a certain hero just play that hero
and just play a lot of them and I think
you'll get better I think the best thing
to learn is like how to work with
everyone else
like that's one of the main things
you'll want to focus on I think Alex
Earle is Moira is only on the PTR
so that's PC public test realm but if
you have PC overwatch you can try her
out
for for you for now I think she was
available around two maybe a little bit
before that her Golden Gun COC Raiders
is basically her rings and her little
like wrist attachments are gold so it's
kind of minor let's say we just looked
at them though so you could scrub back
in the video player to see that
Dino I don't know when we're ovie out on
console because it'll have to be when
she's out proper and available for
everybody
it could be like two weeks maybe yeah
we're just saying that between the
Sombra doofus kind of released they're
usually around one to two weeks after
PTR so we'll see heal them
for judge Joey your boat you're not a
DPS well you can well here right now I
am because there's like 1200 does eleven
I'm just gonna hang back right here and
see Christ or 0-4 is a Hanzo main so he
thinks Mora is not gonna be too hard for
him because it's simple geometry it's
probably similar but you know these
range Joey what slower-moving you know
how far you can shoot they don't yeah I
know but they're also facing me so well
fade behind them they're just lining up
get that play of the game baby oh that
one has it to fade on them is that like
a David Bowie tribute skin I would think
so pretty similar young Vicky Vick the
orbs are always the same size you can't
hold it to change the how big they are
how much damage they do the only thing
you can really affect is if you do the
heal one or the damage one and then how
it bounces off the walls if you do we
did good job there was one time when joy
was kind of bouncing them between two
walls so if you can figure that out and
maximize that that healing or that
damage that would be best
shooting him into like rooms or bored or
far those will do way more damage
obviously thanks oh you don't even know
he's got the heal you don't need to be
you guys close we test right behind you
you did what if the hook is this Opie
Symetra [ __ ] it's okay so what we tested
is that definitely more range or more
route but you have to be more accurate
then if you are playing with Symetra so
you can't just like hold it down and
jump around in one eye you lose you lose
it pretty quickly if you're not like
pretty close yeah it is a little
forgiving but not as much as symmetric
but it has three times the range so
blackpool EDG saying I might buy PC
overwatch anyways because the
sensitivity is not good on console yeah
I mean it's it's definitely harder so
you know do some of the aiming with
certain characters or being able to spin
around as fast on console I mean
obviously you could up the the
sensitivity Red King is now realizing
the range of which you can actually
attack from the heel is not that far
though no I'm pretty much like yeah more
like submission between 5 and 10 yards
oh god it's just a light show laser
light show
so you'd notice there Joey lost the
damage nice trying to kill that one guy
did you just go under the ground he'd
see what would it look like when you
aimed it down at didn't talents but damn
just giving I'm trying to read as many
comments as possible is this supposed to
be mmm effing support yes but she's
kinda like a hybrid kind of like say
yeah she can do damage or she can heal
and like you said it kind of forces you
do you know once you run out of oh just
fade on them yeah you got no oh no oh
you're good someone else is healing I'm
trying to read as many comments as I can
guys if I missed it just put a question
in front of it and I'll try to read it
sorry about that one of them thought you
had an n/a alt there nad induce any
actually at least took a round from the
Koreans it's pretty good but you know
the Koreans of course went back to back
in the World Cup go far this is oh my
god oh you're crazy
oh no problem this is PTR gooo
nobody will use to measure after this I
don't think that's true I think
symmetric turrets and yeah that's like
still very good search space low shield
generator like those are invaluable in
some cases are her achievements on PTR I
don't know not sure we can take a look
yeah Brian if I missed a question of
yours I apologize I just sent it to
again I'll take a look a man some people
want to know how to counter yeah dan
rector sorry I like machree
it's my boobs anyone died in this match
yes damage is weak heal is strong yeah I
mean her damage is not doesn't seem like
yeah like you said earlier I think none
of her abilities feel too strong one way
or the other
yeah you're like they all they all kinda
poor each other so like when you when
you do damage again that's what
recharges your heal so it's it's it
there is a little bit of damage like if
you get like a couple people on you can
it'll be pretty useful it's just that
it's kind of like they kind of just like
balance each other you know I think some
would put someone's day
I thought I thought something I thought
someone uh no I have not I mean we
haven't compared more as he'll versus
Mercy's I would have to think Mercy's is
better but I think more as can
potentially can I hit more than one
person in front of her at one time I
feel like it's more forgiving right you
could just like it's like a spray paint
yeah spray paint in front of you you
know so it's not like you have to like
attach to someone you're like locked to
them really a second or two this one you
can like switch targets really easily
yes grand thief she is on PCP tiara now
I guess PTR is only on PC but yeah
he sprays OH just have the regular
overwatch spray so the heel can't lock
no it's not meant to lock you aim it
yourself and she does have a meter as
you can see that's recuperating and as
Joey mentioned you have to use the drain
which is her right-click ability to kind
of speed that process back up so but you
guys think she's balanced again it's
very hard for me to say if she's
balanced cuz we're playing in a know
like limits 6v6 Morra environment I
don't think she's she doesn't appear to
be like Opie I mean the only thing if
someone wants to argue about what feels
kind of crazy is the range of her damage
I guess other than that I don't feel
like anything outside of that seems too
crazy right like an I think that's like
the only thing we've noticed that's like
oh that's pretty crazy
yeah like is her the range of her damage
but like you said it still takes a good
5 or 6 seconds to actually kill someone
and they can they can maneuver you still
have to aim so yeah I think it's really
she doesn't seem crazy right now but
yeah she is not out on Xbox or ps4 right
now it's also really hard to tell when
the other opposing aura is also draining
you and you're just kind of like a
locked in this quick endless endless
loop and like that the the ability where
you throw the the heel or the damaged
ball doesn't seem too crazy you thinking
you buy it but it's like it doesn't
generally hit you more than like once
maybe twice depending on like if you're
in a small room or not but like an open
area chances are maybe you get hit by it
twice and it didn't even seem to do like
that much when he got hit by I'll try to
I take a look at the day I mean to me it
takes a while the nurse she she's still
a human she's not damage dealer
Cole H doesn't think she's that balanced
I mean I don't know we all just run you
know sure I mean it's pretty hard kyster
I don't know how us you give her a
golden weapon he's not happy with the
golden four nor the golden per diem fist
Hey
that's their weapon yeah I mean what are
you gonna do like I feel like a lot of
their weapons have just been what always
for those who they've just been a part
of them it's not like an external thing
Jake Harding and you teach a saying that
he thinks that the damage range should
get nerfed a little bit but the healing
range should get increased I don't know
I could see that happening if if it
turns out like this freaking 30 rate
2020 range maybe and like 10 range heal
instead of like the five to seven it is
knowing I'm trying to chase this guy to
heal you are healing cuz like you can
see the glow right I'll try to remember
that Cole that your name is actually
Clayton but chances are I may forget
that so a lot of people have a lot of
opinions considering she just came out
outside of Blizzcon I mean they did test
her in a more realistic two setting like
at Blizzcon so oh dude they did AI mean
didn't touch there was like a stream
with some pro players that were playing
playing at least some matches it was
hard for me at Blizzcon to because
everyone or most people were playing
moira to get a feel for and only
sometimes where they're like a few
heroes a few players playing different
only where there a couple times where a
few people are actually playing here
she felt good though as a support I
don't know she's definitely not your
primary but in like be kind of like 2 to
2 beta yeah that is I think she could
definitely be one of the two saws and
yato is being used decent medals at the
World Cup there's a junk rat - all right
people are getting serious the alt looks
Opie but it doesn't do that much damage
yeah and the heel didn't seem insane
when you were healing boy why are you
guys playing whare they got three
Moira's well that's hard to say to Jason
Jake party are you speaking more from a
competitive point of view or from like a
like quick playing competitive point of
view
I mean I guess you could argue Alana
still pretty like darn good and I mean
balance changes will happen too so you
say yeah she got bucked a little bit
yeah I'm just saying well cuz he was
talking about there's better option so
I'm just thinking about the other
supports like Ana's there may be better
like raw healing options but like for
her it's all about like what would you
would you use her as in Yana tho cuz
like I saw people actually using
zenyatta yeah that's the current meta
right so I would say is any Ana's good
against certain teams just because of
like the discus court or changes
everything so much cuz that that's where
you get all your dive comes in like okay
so Jake was talking more from
competitive yeah I mean want to see how
she plays out in competitive I just want
like I'd be nice to see just a normal
match to but no why me oh so if you
faded that at the right time yeah you
could you could you could avoid it and
you that would be really fast I'm like
that would be a dual reaction on
reactions yeah I like doing that with
Zarya though putting the bubble up and
then they just blow it up and charge me
up so that orb actually slows down when
it gets to another player they all teal
seems pretty strong to me says Lourdes
Evans I think in certain instances it's
gonna be pretty good right like
especially when you're like pushing a
payload in a lane kind of thing where
you can kind of just like wave it around
yeah cuz you're gonna do damage and heal
so low mobility seems to be a serious
weakness yeah but I mean Zenyatta is
like crappy mobility here dude this and
her fade ability is actually quite good
it's just that she can't use it for
verticality in play Oh
geometry Jefferson saying having
resource meter on healing seems like a
weakness but I think it's part of the
character it's like you drain to get
more healing I don't know we'll have to
see I mean maybe they look at the meter
and this maybe it's like not enough off
the initial kind of gotcha
just don't get slapped don't get okay
rocket piston man she's only shown it's
200 HP Ethan you can't fade upwards or
downwards you can fade mid-jump and then
you can go like left to right up or back
you can also kind of like diagonally go
in a way I guess do it's just that
there's no vertical yeah you just can't
look up and be like I want to go to that
ramp for a while I thought you you were
able to do that with tracer I always
tried to do that would have been so good
for an alt yeah yeah J carding says when
she uses drains she fills her meter and
heals result I didn't realize she healed
herself - oh my god oh here things are
getting real serious here
McKenzie thumbs up and joke read did you
watch the panel at all about how they're
talking about like tightening after the
fact and all they're like different
heroes they could have had like the
concepts are you thank you mama Hong oh
I saw yeah I saw that uh the images of
them yeah that was crazy and like seeing
the the game in like pre develop or
early developments age it was pretty
cool I think
is all together made - oh yeah all those
all those heroes yeah so you got like
watcher Helio Troy hivemind
firestarter we think I was like Pharoah
ironclad which is tr inside blade
Angelica who is obviously mercy
mama Hong mama home mama Hong some of
this is cut off UNIX yeah I gotta call
them a cloud with Winston's in there is
Winston yeah I think like those are I
think a Reaper fara tracers wasting
we're like the first ones that they
finalized I think as far as the designs
go oh and then the maps are cool too
you didn't get it huh okay and see those
plated TVs yeah like kyoto temple
obvious moving amazon san joaquin
there's some pretty good stuff there if
you guys didn't see that panel but yeah
did she have a passive i if she did I
didn't see it I can't oh I'm the new
owner of the game sick order of business
um I guess the only maybe the only
passive ability you could've eaten call
that is that her her damage beam also
brings her yeah drains life basically
and it helps fill the he only bought her
golden guns already let me just said
it's only things out gr mone to and it's
not like you're gonna lose them fluffy
the squirrel asked to the voice actor or
actress for more to look it up the
that first one
I'm gonna have to take a look load
someone saying Genevieve O'Reilly yes
sir
this is Michael she voice acted so
Genevieve O'Reilly voice actress or
morons in the matrix 1 yeah
rogue one Matrix Revolutions Star Wars
Episode three who was she in real one
I'll tell you ok she is also in Star
Wars rebels
she was Mon Mothma I do not remember
that was oh it's uh Oh her do you oh yes
so she was like the rebel like kind of
like a head of the rebel yeah army at
the table ok question does the beam go
through divas defense matrix because I
think the beam doesn't go through
Reinhard shield by me like um like
saria's beam it goes through the defense
matrix either I'm just wondering if it's
the same thing cuz it all absorbed jek
tiles I'm not sure if it's what is
considered
oh you're here - put it up get it there
- what scrap good 1s camera wood hard to
say I think she's a fun character but I
play a lot as in yatta so I like having
the event I like to I like playing
support and but also being able to be
damaged so this is like right up my
alley yeah we showed her Moroz emotes
her skins if you guys are scrubbed back
in the video player no secondary ability
for healing shooting says yes she does
her dad ability also heals it bounces
around and heals teammates okay
everyone's Altan nobody's dying oh oh
triple oh oh oh you should have just
like faded red guy just to show how
vulnerable it is head of the rebels yes
manhua Jake Harding saying yes it does
go through defense matrix just so you
know I think I saw that near the end it
apparently also goes through Ganges
reflect
yeah that's love those things that like
they tried to they try to put up the
defense matrix or deflect it and they
can't whatever I'm sorry be the meat
shield
no dog please live your whole we hold
kicking you're gonna have to start
draining oh yeah where's that turret dad
for spudger orb can be deflected yeah
sure here
take some ping-pong with it that's not
third one she's had already okay is that
a path on the left still there you think
it fade no way too far I think listen if
you go off it does take take all three
of tracers to get across right yeah I
don't think you can try for science Oh
oh my god laser show Oh
Noah's dying
so does that also give you life back to
them yeah okay pretty sure that's like
man
how's she give you all these firing she
the counter the hard camera I don't know
I think it's just because we have no
other nobody else to get through yeah
held onto it oh no man you can escape
every alt with her shadow - yeah if
anything they might like think please to
cool down for it I can see them doing
that for fade it's not a 70 second
cooldown or 650 they're six or seven I
think [ __ ] her movement otherwise is
pretty up her movement otherwise is kind
of very just average or below average if
that even should she'll get that extra
movie speed with her old books do you
think you get a sorriest thing I think
so right so how far you don't know
because I thought they
I thought they turn now but they buffed
her a couple dashes ago where I think it
was like you couldn't get out using like
tracers is their shadow - like triggers
tracers blink it's where you're moving
and not looking yeah that's right
so like you can hold back or strafe and
then and then activate it you'll go in
that direction
mm-hmm all right Joey I'll give you one
more okay and we're gonna call it a
stream cool but I do appreciate everyone
tuning in again if you guys didn't know
she's out on PC currently if you have PC
play her oh sorry she got on PC PTR not
out on actual PC but yeah oh right I am
the the owner of this room now um start
you just started oh that's so people are
telling you to do yeah does she have a
Zen heal or mercy heal I mean she has a
heal to left-click it goes what like 5
to 7 meters
yeah awfully has to be pretty close
range
hate or
schon Shoom asking do you think that
reaper shadowstep should be closer to
more jump in timing hmm I mean how much
how much longer is Reapers cooldown
I mean maybe is he talking about like
the like how long it takes activated
it's it's a pretty long time it's like a
second before he actually disappears I
think that'd be too good then right if
he already has he has like the refill
the rate the ability to teleport it's
just always fun teleport and you're just
waiting on the other side takes it
forever to actually zoom in is there an
all more game well yeah we're playing
right now five more risen oh and a mercy
oh she got nerfed this patch - what
happened her you know how they changed
her resurrect yeah so just II they gave
that a cast time now and she can also be
interrupted by it
oh really yeah like if you shoot her at
all it stops yeah how long is the cast
time oh well a second one point seven
five seconds damn is she gonna fall off
the meta then probably but I mean her
her old is so good it still gives it
like instant and it gives you two
charges of it so it's useful just I
don't think mercy is gonna be required
anymore especially since they they
bumped on a little bit and yeah Maura
so I love Biasi thing that she looks
like a 3-star kind of character
positioning is key yeah two stars but
it's all about that geometry yeah I
think it's all that is pretty like
subjective yeah she's definitely has
some Symetra vibes
I think Symetra is and yada like a
little bit of Reaper I guess she kind of
got the fade facepalm spray
Moira's and known aims in yada
she still gotta aim a little bit yeah
even more than Symetra yeah it's been
proven
got somebody
it's lying around in there oh you don't
want to be in that room that's all right
look at that
herbs yeah
is that range Oh
oh no don't go too far don't grant okay
running out of healing I mean you got
the e baby still got Yi get ping-pong it
against the wall it's wrong one
oh wait wasn't no how does he know for
other people shooters in there he'll
scare me yes'm maybe supposed to be like
a witch you know she's like a mad
scientist we look gonna have backboard
Bank it's still open oh and physics Oh
unibeam oh wow yeah
oh god rest wait is it very the tapper
heel or continually use it I think it
depends Preston but I mean I think that
if you want more healing you have to
hold it down you know right click drain
to get your ability to heal faster again
she getting a Christmas skin who knows I
mean considering she has a decent she
has two legendary stones already do
fiscal house she'd be like karela
deville would that be a good one oh wait
we can't do Disney they can't even say
Disneyland interview presentation so
theme park
it's not so much cooldown Soula it's
like the meter that you use or have to
use up for healing no no no the only way
to get the meter back faster if you
revived oh there's that there's a cast
time now the only way to get it back as
if you do the dream life so it comes it
comes back way faster if you dream life
so it's like a reason to do damage acts
you know it's like it's it's pretty much
necessary
okay so Ling Ling said yeah there she
did try to res you but she died so
that's why
yeah use that range so you notice that
Joey use like two-thirds of his meter oh
no it comes acting quickly Oh No
orbs just going everywhere you guys can
react quickly mercy
she's Vernon's alright I guess it will
do attacking suni that happens lightning
gave me not sure when she actually comes
out proper she's just out on PTR yeah I
think the last ones for Sombra and
Arisa I think one to two weeks right
yeah I think it was so I think one of
them yeah one of them was one week in
the rest for two weeks but yeah you can
expect like sometime this month yep
Preston that was the mercy nerf probably
testing that out too is my guess
to see if that's too long or good enough
but ya know a lot of the peeler changes
this batch yeah that changed that meta
man with talents or though is it gonna
make you play the other side I think so
okay
three two one yes Lillian mentioned in
confirm 1.75 seconds for that res she
gets stunned or interrupted her resolute
Ansel sometimes he'll still break Sarah
Kay cabinets at least console will be
even longer so we're we're estimating
complete guests on our part hopefully
one to two weeks
but who knows you guys will know the
moment we find out as I'm sure there
will be news about it yeah mercy
interrupts seems like overkill yeah I
mean if it takes one point seven five
seconds already that seems kind of tough
as is but you know it does it does then
kind of force the skill shotting and
whatnot a little bit like it makes it
just special
I guess because like I don't know her
being able to read so easily before was
just kind of like like whenever wouldn't
be getting like that one target that
you're like hoping to get and then just
comes back to life just like that so
easily
kind of a downer ling-ling her range is
actually more than 20 meters we are able
to shoot her drain life at like 30
meters in the test range no I think her
her alt is third or alt sturdy so then
my bad it's been a long weekend
yeah 20 meters is pretty long to put
that into perspective it's almost like
three times Symetra range for her right
click yeah 30 meters for her ultimate
though just honest I believe we did you
go through all the voice lines I did it
we can do that sir we could do all that
everything after yeah for those asking
like the skins and everything soon says
when have you ever seen mercy res out of
combat the inner of will put her on the
bench for the meta possible and it's
also possible that they don't stick to
1.75 or that they maybe don't keep the
interrupts this is PTR unless they said
for sure that that's gonna happen do you
know if that's the case I mean those are
the changes for right now I can always
modify them later on its sorry it was 30
meters for her super and 20 meters for
her right click so I misspoke but Joey
corrected me as he should a new new
spray
how are you playing Morris as fire kills
she is on PTR holy jesus that skin his
badass hazmat we do Janeiro
yep pretty cool a little I would assume
- oh no what people are dying
oh you are a healer Oh Symmetra turrets
you got to right-click those you can't
work it
[Music]
okay probably should wait like oh this
is orbs everywhere just thank you
spiking David Bowie album sales I don't
know I appreciate the gesture where we
go look at that range going down
nice oh they don't want to be in that
room
no you don't know no you don't they
should have went in well as their Golden
Gun she gets gold rings and the gold
bracelet you'll see that after we'll go
through everything that you guys need to
see in the menus you guys do like she
can use those orbs Oh what is this right
here it's gonna take me forever to kill
but these nobody come out I'm surprised
the Metra isn't oh okay good
Williams teleporter pad yes you don't
know you don't know
oh the chase Oh too much healing God
where is everyone know what there's one
person there sorry man I had to I had to
leave
ratchet turrets
oh I don't know if they can actually be
leached just just honest that's a good
question
do you think that you could leach us
turret if you killed it
that's a good question like I assume
that when you use your right-click it's
just all damaged do you think she'll be
meta nerfed or buff I don't know I think
it's too I think it's too early to tell
we know that we can heal ourselves with
the ability as well as right-click Joe
will drain the light this game is not
called plate beyblade it's called
overwatch but I know the beyblades the
spinning top games
she's still alive oh nice what you gonna
do you think she's got turret or I mean
announcer a teleporter oh it's a trap
dunno I wonder if the ball windmills
those you think the balls come
definitely oh that's really good she
showed you you didn't get any turrets
maybe is it go through or maybe someone
else got them
[Music]
yeah it's in the freaking room I don't
think it did oh wow two of those do
quite a bit of damage though huh yeah
she's definitely not gonna be the
primary healer she would be this the one
you would run as like the off healer
probably yeah
no one there battle of the pantaloons if
you guys she's just a cluster oh yeah
give that range in that range
oh it is you don't see me oh you got 15
seconds to clean this objective okay
we're good this is turqu doing here
doing his geometry
of over time
you don't know you don't I bet you
jumping like that pie minute way hardly
know him the only time I do that is if I
was healing oh I dare you see oh he
tried it okay owner maybe that one
though maybe that one jumping that that
top one no no the top one the top one no
it's not gonna work
they can't even get there but that's
that's distance not a height oh [ __ ] no
that's I think I believe I believe I
believe I believe you barely aim it up
aim it up a little bit even though
that's not how it works
haha alright I I needed to know I needed
to know don't growth make it over though
oh I ruined your fire my that's cool it
was worth trying I don't know why would
she reminds me of animals I'm just
honored to see that are you
I think we're as interesting I think she
could be good but again we need to see
her in some more practical scenarios
than 66 issues morals Wow that damage
there had to have been like three of
them there right I don't know it wasn't
the only did 3000 whoops Oh yep mm-hmm
fat-fingered what's this play out so
nobody nobody sees it
oh that guy saw it saw that coming
hashtag believe clearly it didn't work
hits anyone I think we needed a little
bit I think her fade means a little bit
more distance so she can clear that a
little gap
what the what the oh that's brilliant
too many orbs I have one very fine no
problem yeah I don't know I don't know
I'm not seeing this now with your team
calm because when they fought you guys
they had more than oh please playing
Widow oh you're this guy man this guy
tryharding you know 66 must hate healers
and Moira's goop sang junk art works
pretty well against it yeah yeah he
knows he could throw his orb to heal
himself if he wants to do damage with it
so where is my team I hear some turtle
thing
oh this one junk rats gonna do work okay
sneak up and steal the point
oh just good okay I'm healing myself
she's kidding
13:30 oh no put yourself in a corner
nobody puts you in a corner unless it's
himself yeah Fair Haven drin even DRAM
yeah oh my lord
oh there's so many oh you can run for it
[Music]
yeah I don't think this is happening
okay though
did the most objective kills always go
for that gold objective time yeah you
just fade into a corner hope no one sees
you
oh this is this the run everyone okay
you got two kills and all your yep
molten cord though well then one second
get on the point yep I'll just hide in
the corner in the corner I'm just gonna
I got a heal oh I still left he's good
believe no one's on the nose on the
point all right I want you yeah we're
gonna show everything right so you just
leave this game yeah we're gonna go show
off all the skins all the emotes all the
highlight intros and the voice stuff and
then we're probably gonna call it a wrap
all right so we got her classical in
here just like the black and purple
fiery royal purple here
selkie teal almost right there and then
whiskey that doesn't remind me of
whiskey or Nate's which is like a pale
gray and green there she has some cool
skins actually I like that one thing is
clean the minister got like like almost
like the stars on her arm yeah Oasis
color variant I think the other ones
cooler and then moon which is uh one of
the David Bowie probably inspired like
the face paint yeah and I currently have
this one here show that gold weapon for
the gold was it wrist straps or whatever
yeah rings gold jewelry accessories
accessorize what does she always she
only has a nose ring in the in the
scanner and
yeah so I thought and then emotes we're
sitting the bow
I'm guessing come here laughs okay
thanks victory poses I shake on one of
these earlier got the orbs rim oh she's
stealing the church are you finished
brilliant brand I'm working idle hands
are the devil's workshop one hand gives
the other takes away stupidity is not a
right the state of you what are you on
about
you're a chancer it was a chancer hell
no okay Irish slang and then I haven't
seen her sprays really cool uh I guess
can you end on showing the gold weapon
again someone said sprays there's her
sprays facepalm its fade mr. icon that
was on a shirt I think any shirt I think
what Geoff Caplan was wearing that one
yep hypothesis yeah what was her what's
her backstory she's like she was
originally part of overwatch I think
Julie and she was doing all this
research but then they deemed it kind of
like unsafe basically she's she isn't
necessarily like
usual person I think she cares more
about like the science and what she
needs to do to kind of make that science
come to life or you know to do whatever
it takes for her to prove her theories
and so she ultimately you know needed
more money more funding and stuff like
that so then she ended up joining Rhea's
I think and were Talent
yeah and so then she started working
with them and the stories that's how she
ended up the way she where she's at but
it's not necessarily that she's an evil
person per se but yeah she will do
whatever it takes to kind of make the
science that she wants to happen happen
so yeah that is pretty much it thank you
guys all for tuning in that was Maura
currently out on PC public test realm so
if you have her army sorry if you have
PC overwatch you can hop on and download
the PTR download the update and you'll
be able to play 66 Moira essentially and
until we know yeah and until we
apparently it's Irish slang and the
state of U is also an insult all right
good to know thank you Jeff Glynn so
yeah when she comes out I'm sure you'll
find out from us maybe it's a week or
two we don't know what are your thoughts
I guess final thoughts after playing her
Joey pretty fun like I said before I
don't think that she's like overpowered
either in healing or damage I think like
the design of the character is like the
balance between the two so I think it
probably even now like once it gets
closer to release and once we actually
start playing with actual team comps
like I say it's pretty much every time
just because we always end up playing
against eleven other of the same
characters but you know I feel the same
way about Moira - she's very she's very
solid yeah in like her damage and
healing yeah so ratchet
Satan is correcting me which I
appreciate saying that pretty sure that
she was never an overwatch but in Tallin
Blackwatch yeah
so telling Black Watch and then her way
she was part of overwatch covert ops
team Black Watch okay and then
eventually you know yeah anyways you can
look up her origin story which is also
out so if I'm wrong you can figure that
out from that so but otherwise
you guys all for tuning in we appreciate
it and until next time tomorrow I'll see
you guys at 11:00 hopefully destiny
update but until next time thank you
guys all and have a good one later